Oh, he's unique. What is
finding Hitler all about? Um,
this is the show that you're on and it's
on a and e, is that what's on? Yeah,
Amy is the parent network.
It airs on history channel and we just
had our third season that just finished
airing. What's the thought process
behind this? This is this, is it legit?
Cause a lot of people are like finding
Hitler. Get the fuck out of here.
They found Hitler. He died. Yeah. I
mean not really. We don't know. Right.
That that's the, that's the, I mean this
isn't like ancient aliens. This is whee.
They declassified a bunch of documents.
They,
both the Israelis and the British and
the Germans and Americans in the past 20
years have been consistently
declassified documents.
And there were a bunch of specifically
FBI documents that we were spending
millions and millions of dollars actively
searching for Hitler after the war.
As was, yeah. Like millions of dollars.
Like Hoover was like, no, no, no, no.
Send more FBI agents to South
America and to North Africa.
Go to the Canary Islands,
go to Spain.
Trying to find out where this guy went.
Songs of real FBI
documents with real leads,
with real informants,
some hand or some first I accounts
saying that they physical.
So anyways,
that's the show is us trying to find out,
sift through reality and um,
the fiction of the, the allure, the mist,
the mystery of that asshole.
So what's the official story?
The official story is that he
killed himself, right? Yep. Yeah.
Killed himself in the bunker
with David Braun. Yup.
And is there any photographic
evidence of his death or anything?
So what the Russians got the
body and they got his school.
Um,
and when they brought it back to Moscow,
nobody has ever been able to independently
verify who and what this body is.
They let one genetic tests occur and the
body and with a bullet holes that they
said was Hitler and have said, and
that's the narrative. That's a story.
That's the all the eye witness accounts
that are in even in the vicinity of
collaborating with each other and
cooperating each other's testimony.
Like the closest version, cause none
of it seems to be very accurate.
Is that okay, here's Hitler skull.
And when they did the genetic testing,
it's that of a 35 year
old woman. So like, oh,
well this isn't Hitler,
but they've said for the past 80
years that this is Hitler. So,
okay, first before we start
throwing stones at Russia,
let's go back to 1945
April, um, Ma in Berlin,
you have the allies coming in,
wrecking shop, dropping bombs,
blowing everything up.
They can in every single which way you
have the Russians coming in from the
opposite direction. They don't even have
enough guns to arm all their soldiers.
So if they have 200 guys or 200,000 guys,
they have 100,000 guns at the guy in front
of you dies. You just pick up his gun.
That's what's happening in
April of 1945 in Berlin.
So the noose is tightening.
There is no,
I mean it is chaos and arche
pandemonium. This, I mean you couldn't,
this is hell on earth is Berlin, 1945. So,
I don't know if you could
get a real story, a real,
the way that we do it now,
where we have, you know,
this forensic experts that come in and
document everything and we'd look at all
the different testimonies say this
is this exactly how, it's just not,
it's not CSI. This is
1945 Berlin. It's crazy.
So I don't know.
There's,
there was no like absolute proof
and a lot of Nazis did escape
and go to South America.
The majority of anyone with power,
the Nuremberg trials
were not a witch hunt,
but it was to close a chapter so we can
start moving forward with communism.
That's what it was.
The threat of fascism,
the threat of Hitler, the, the
threat of killing all the Jews,
the threat of world domination
by the Nazis that threat's gone.
What's the next threat? Tommy
does this communism, right?
So that had to be a closed chapter
of our history so we could focus our
resources and our efforts to what
inevitably was going to, I mean,
the wall goes up. We have east
and West Berlin, you know,
we're already looking at Korea. I mean
this, this happens almost overnight,
very quickly. No one
patents like no, no homies.
We need to go all the way to Matt Moscow.
This is not the end of our war.
And we didn't listen to him.
Um, we then had been, you know,
fighting communism for the past 75 years.
So the ones with power
that went to South America,
I know a bunch of them went to
Argentina. Uh, they think, uh,
they went to Honduras and
a few other places where,
where do they think they wound up?
So what you had in South America,
both Chile and Argentina back to
back had fascist receipt regimes.
You had a person who was part of the
Nazi party starting all the way back into
the mid thirties.
He's the president of Argentina.
So the Red Cross, um, they
were facilitating that.
There was about three different rat
lines that guys were able to successfully
get out of Europe into South America.
Um,
and these are, there's no question
that we're talking thousands,
if not tens of thousands of high ranking
Nazis made it there. Tens of thousands,
tens of thousands.
And I'm not talking like little soldiers.
I'm talking high ranking Nazis officer's
got guys like Joseph Mengele and Adolf
Eichmann.
I mean these are the most disgusting
despicable humans to exist at the time.
If Hill,
if Hitler is dead,
Joseph Mengele is the guy that would
take syringes full of blue ink and inject
them and you have blue eyes,
Joe, or you have brown eyes.
Let me see if I can make them blue.
Oh Wow.
And then take twins and start torturing
them to see if one would feel the pain.
That's Josef Mengele.
I mean that's the guy that then
in South America was helping, um,
high ranking Argentinians have
abortions and he set up, um,
have you seen the movie Colonia
about Koininia, dignity dad,
which is that if you're
listening right now,
almost warn you not to
Google it because it is,
it was a torture camp that
was started by Joseph Shafer,
a Nazi and Josef Mengele,
the,
the doctor of death that escaped
trial in Nuremberg and made it,
um,
at the behest of Parone into Argentina.
He set up the hospital at Colonia Dignan
Dad, which was another safe house,
safe haven for more Nazis
in South America. Um,
go to my air and David and Ben
Gurion, the presidents of Israel, um,
they,
they took the gloves off and they were
just sending an assassin's to try and
find these people and killed them.
Um,
but what you got in South America
were isolated German only communities.
You could go into Bariloche,
Argentina, and you know, I'd be like,
what will it is Migos and they
were like Guten Morgen Oh yeah,
good morning. Yeah.
Sorry. It's 2017. Right?
I thought we spoke Spanish here in 2017
you were there and they were speaking
German. Yeah. Whoa. Why
I'm, I don't look very,
I might look more European than I do show
is just them seeing me walking on the
street and be like, wow. And
there's tons of communities. I mean,
if you go to Colonia Dicta Dad,
which is now called via Bavaria,
the Bavarian village,
it is a only German wow.
In the center of Chile,
in the mountains of Chile.
Like you, there's no Spanish
beans being spoken there.
It is exclusively German and
these are descendants of Nazis.
Powerful Nazis. Holy Shit. And
this is going on right now. Yeah.
Yeah. What are these communities like?
I mean, what's their ideology or they,
I mean, they're pretty white. Yeah.
What are they like? I mean, are they,
do they espouse Nazi values are
not openly so colonia dignity dad?
Uh, if you look at the second
generation, there's a bunch of,
so it was a huge problem for Chile that
they tried to hide for years and they
got so much power from the torturing
that they did at Colonia dicta dad on a
whole bunch of other PR,
high ranking South American dictators
that they're almost untouchable.
And this, this is, I mean,
you, you, you would blow your
mind if you look into this,
Joe, you'd, you'd love it.
But, um, the second generation,
the kids like the grandkids,
sometimes they're even more fanatical
than the original generation.
Have you ever seen this?
Where like if somebody is away from,
like when you travel abroad and it's so
cool to like to get into the culture and
get into the food and get into the,
like you're dancing this style and your,
you love the flag and you're like,
oh,
I'm gonna go to a soccer game because we
don't go to soccer games in America and
I'm going go. But then maybe after
like two months, you kind of miss home,
you know,
and then like a year,
you really miss home and then 10 years,
like you really,
really miss home.
And you see the same thing in the United
States where it's not really a perfect
assimilation.
It's not the melting pot where you see
generations that are espousing to be more
like their ethnic heritage than
they are American. You know,
they're flying the Irish flag.
And like, I'm, I'm Irish, um,
what's just times a thousand with these
communities because they're exclusively
German. Oh yeah. It's
pretty cool. Kind of weird.
So exclusively German and
really missing home. Yeah.
Yeah. So in the years later, the
second generations I was talking about,
um,
some of them came to the United States
and were high ranking white supremacists
that are now in jail and
prison for their racial crimes.
And they came out of South America.
They came out of Colonia dignity
ad that came out of bear low che.
They came out of Cordova. They came out
of Miss Joan as they came out of, yeah.
Wow. It's crazy. So that's
the show hunting Hitler
fucking amen to spread.
How many people are we talking about?
All told in South America
that can come out of this,
I mean tens of thousands went there,
but how many German communities and what,
how big are they?
I mean maybe have 50 German communities.
50. How many people, if you had
to guess, a few hundred thousand.
Holy Shit.
Hundred thousand descendants of Nazis.
Wow.
Yeah.
And me,
and it's weird when you walk into
somebody's parlor and it's like you're
stepping back in time into
Europe. Like I'm walking in, it's,
it's 2017 and I'm walking in Buenos Aires,
Argentina into somebody parlor.
And all of the tile is European and all
of the style and all the art is very
German. You know, we have
like deers and you know, not,
not like red stags, what we're
talking German, everything,
things that Hiller loved. And
that's the style. That's everything.
And then they come out and like with white
gloves, they're holding their GRANDPA,
their grandfathers, um,
memory box and inside of it,
or his war medals from,
you know,
when he was in the ss or when he was,
and it is the respect the,
I don't even know the right ones.
Yeah. I mean it's like, Whoa, it's the,
this is a gift from the pope that they're
holding their hands. White gloves. No,
I can't. First of all, Tim can't touch
it. That's, but I can appreciate it.
And then they tell me the story of every
single one of these things and how he
got there and how he then went and
for the Buenos Aires news can't touch
anything. Oh, they wouldn't know cause
I come, you'll you're dirty, dirty,
dirty American. He's to
Brown. Yeah. Fuck man.
So we followed the first two seasons.
It was really just unraveling the
rumors of what happened to Hitler.
The third season was my favorite
because I actually got to do real work.
They said, okay, I got it.
The second season I got to bring in
more special forces guys. Um, uh,
CIA targeter, Nadia, um,
who helped my unit kill Zarqawi in
2006 that this is the team that is now
looking at real evidence
trying to figure out, okay,
how did we find Bin Ladin how
do we find Secar is our county.
We looked at their associates and we
looked at how they move that we looked at
how the communicated,
we looked at what routes they were
using to get to and from places.
And then we just started
tightening the noose.
And that's exactly what we did
in this third season was, okay,
let's start following the Adolf Eichmann.
Let's start following the Joseph main
glaze and let's start falling the scores
and skis.
Um,
Hitler's personal body guard that was a
colonel in the ss that went on to work
for everybody after the war fighting.
I mean,
fascists do not like communists.
So this guy was working for everybody
to include the CIA fighting fascism in
South America or fighting communism
as a fascist in South America in the
fifties, sixties and seventies.
Whoa. Creepy stuff. Whoa. Yeah.
So,
so hunting hiller are there any legitimate
eye witness accounts of Hitler and
South America or potentially
legitimate? Absolutely. Potentially.
Whoa. Yup. I witness counts.
I saw him get off the boat.
I saw him meet here and if it
was just some person saying it,
it's almost meaningless.
Right?
But if you look at the
context of who this person is,
the wealth that they have that
they shouldn't have, and I can,
can you explain how you got so rich
and two generations you're like, okay,
your grandpa got here from
Germany in 1946. That's weird.
Um, and he, he,
he's on a legitimate visa with an
Argentinian passport, also weird.
Um, and now he's a war refugee
that's now worth millions of dollars.
How does this, how does this work? Um, so,
but people,
and then this is the hard part.
People want to be connected to significant
events and especially in small rural
areas of the world, um, developing
areas like they want, they're so nef,
they're so little happening. They want
to be attached to something massive.
And like the fact that they saw you
boat land on this beach and the pop,
the hatch opened and you know,
this,
these cars were there and they were doing
morse code and this guy gets off and
he had this little
mustache. You're like, well,
for you boats can't beach. That's
not how that works. You know,
and, and, but you know what they're trying
to do. They just want to be connected.
So, and now we're removed 70
to 80 years from the facts. It,
it's has been painful to
try to use real science,
real investigative tools
to try to sift through
this lore, you know, what do
you think happened? I mean,
you've been studying this for how
long now? Three years. Yeah. You,
if you had to guess,
if you had like 1 million bucks,
you've got to put it on one side or
another. Did he go there? Yeah. Whoa.
I, I would say, man, it's, it's,
and that's the first time I've
ever said it flat out like that.
What would I want to say is the
way history is written is wrong.
That that's, that's clear. There's no
way that we can say he died on this day.
This is what happened here is his body.
And that's what his physical proof is
for sure. The woman that that head yeah,
they were saying was Hitler is
definitely not Hitler is absolutely not.
That's a fact. They don't have Hitler's
body. So then our other option was Kate,
is it ava? Brahms did. He just
grabbed the wrong body. Right, right.
So there are still descendants of,
of ava and we tried to have
them allow us to do it.
Then we tried to go through like, um, and
they can get DNA off of the skull. Yes.
Meat on it. It's like a tooth. Yeah. Okay.
And um, but they wouldn't consent to
it. So then we tried to do, you know,
like were people have like the,
the tree, they're ethnic treat
those websites called 23 and me.
Yeah. There's like a bunch of them.
We tried to go that route,
but um,
that wouldn't consent to it. Nope. The Eva
Braun's family, they just want it gone.
They just don't want to, yeah. There are
super pissed that we even found them,
which was hard,
which was really hard.
Hold them down and get them to
spit in the bucket. Yeah. The uh,
I know,
I mean,
or pull their trash and pull stuff out of
there. Now I would totally not do that.
Definitely not do that. Um, but
I mean, that's how they call it.
The golden state killer, right.
Was off a fucking cigarette butts.
They got DNA off a cigarette
butt. So history's wrong. Wow.
Two for it to be black and white like
that and fuck man. And if, and again,
if you go back to 1945,
um, we needed scientists.
We needed every single German electrical
engineer, mechanical engineer,
aerospace, anything. You're on the
[inaudible] program. You, do you know any,
we will, all of you. Because now it's a
race. It's a race. We have the bomb now.
We need delivery systems. Now we need to
get to the moon. Now we need to, you know,
like all of those things are real time.
It's a war, a war of dollars
in a wharf. Science. And um,
we got all those scientists.
Yeah. The Russians didn't, well,
they got some sound. Not very
many. Operation paperclip was what,
what brought over the Wernher von Braun,
who was,
when you talk to Jews that were in Berlin
during the time that Wernher von Braun
was running his rocket program there,
he would hang the five slowest Jews in
front of the rocket factory in Berlin.
Just to give everybody
motivation to work harder. Yeah.
It's the Simon Wiesenthal Center said
that if Wernher von Braun was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes
against humanity. He was a Nazi,
straight up Nazi. And people, there's
apologists that say, no, no, no.
He was a scientist. He was forced into
doing that. Like, that's like, okay,
he's a Nazi. There's photographs of him
wearing Nazi garb hanging out with Nazis.
He, they, his rocket factory
killed Jews like this is,
these are all undeniable facts and sent
the war ends and they're not Nazis.
Exactly how that works.
Exactly. But they were for,
they were forgiven because they came over
and contributed to our rocket program.
I'm not that, I'm not that good of
a human. I don't have that in me.
I don't have that like, okay, it's like.